all week long we've been dishing out
tips and tricks to viewers like you
who may just love design or have a
design dilemma and it is time for a very
special design by drew we heard from a
husband and wife who were looking for
ways to transform their bedroom in their
forever home
oh this was so fun take a look
i'm lilly this is my husband zach we met
on set at work i do hair styling for
filming tv ada special effects little
did we know it slowed down for the whole
world and we were out of a job yep
the pandemic changed everything when we
had to pull out of our mortgage his
parents decided they needed to sell his
childhood home it opened up the doors
and we decided to relocate north of the
city the house has been updated probably
in a little over 40 years there was
nothing that really really thoroughly
liked about the house other than where
it was we ended up tearing out most of
the house and made it more suitable for
our tastes
and stuff
we had our first born oliver who's
amazing we had a lot of catching up to
do once he was born and that's kind of
where all our focus has been on the last
what year and a half his nursery is like
the only room that's been complete our
master has
nothing but a broken bed
he gets in bed i just like slowly roll
over to the side because it's a broken
lopsided bed believe that's what we've
had for over a year it worked but oliver
has his roof set up and he's happy and
that's what matters it would be really
nice to have just a long time together
please help us with our master bedroom
we could really use peace and quiet and
tranquility please help us get our space
back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please more right oh the hormones must
be raging totally
um i love zach
i mean the childhood home yeah tell me
about this it's awesome so i grew up
there i had an older brother and older
sister
growing up there i never realized how
special it was
uh now living there each day i get to
see my son have the same memories that
kind i had
and then a couple probably about six
months ago it really dawned on me when
my uh my sister my yeah my sister my
mother and my sister's son were running
through the backyard and my mom was
chasing both of them so that was
something special to me oh my god
i'm just so glad that your kids are
getting this opportunity
it's really amazing
um why haven't you had time to focus on
the bedroom i feel like the answer is
[Applause]
well with coven not having a job for a
year
right and then his ankle he hurt his
ankle that year and
and then
i we got so lucky
it was so quick
so
yeah so we just haven't had a chance i
don't even know how our bedroom
encouraged this
[Laughter]
well
if it's okay i looked at the before
pictures of your bedroom yes
and um
i got really inspired
very excited okay
um
i really got into it i got really
inspired i sort of did some design
firsts uh for you guys so
um i i rem i redid your bedroom what is
that okay yeah we're so excited
[Music]
you